I've heard that too with problems and
that's why people say sleep on it yeah
yeah you've never been told to stay
awake on a problem sometimes when you're
about to go to bed it's almost
overwhelming you just can't concentrate
on anything else but this problem
whatever it is and then you go to sleep
and you wake up in the morning like it's
alright yeah it's gonna be fine
yeah I got it I know what to do and
sleeps at it you know and there's lots
of anecdotal evidence of sleep inspired
creativity and now this shifts to one of
the benefits of dreaming in fact it's
during dream sleep when we take all of
the information that we've previously
learned and we start to collide it with
all of the new information that we've
learned it's it's a little bit like
group therapy for memories you know
everyone gets a name badge and you all
get to speak to each other and the brain
starts to seek out and test novel
connections and new associations so it's
almost like informational alchemy and
you wake up the next morning with a
revised mind wide web that is now
capable of divining you know incredible
solutions to previously impenetrable
problems and lots of anecdotes you know
dmitri mendeleev came up with a periodic
table of elements by way of dream
inspired insight you know talk about a
Herculean task take all of the elements
in the known universe and figure out a
structure as to how they all fit
together off you go
his waking brain could not do it his
sleeping brain solved the problem I mean
I it's time by the way if this is great
Einstein was suggested to be a short
sleeper and we don't know if that's true
but even if he was he was a habitual
NAPA during the day I've got some great
pictures of him on his workbench and he
used sleep ruthlessly as a tool for
creativity and he would sit at his desk
and he would have a sort of pad of paper
and a pencil and he had her a chair with
arm rests and he would pick up two steel
ball bearings and take a metal saucepan
and turn it upside down place it
underneath the arm of the chair
and put the tool Stiebel steel ball
bearings in his hand then he would rest
back and he would start to fall asleep
and so he didn't fall too far into sleep
what would happen is at some point his
muscle tone would relax they would
release the steel ball bearings they
would crash on the saucepan wake him up
and then he would write down all of the
creative ideas that he isn't how
brilliant so no wonder you're never told
to sort of stay awake on a problem and
in every language that I've inquired
about today
French Swahili that phrase sleeping on a
problem seems to exist which must mean
that this benefit of dream sleep
transcends cultural boundaries
I should note I think it's important
that the French the French translation
is much closer to you you sleep with a
problem we the British you say you sleep
on a problem the French you say you
sleep with a problem I think it says so
much about the romantic difference
between the British and the French you
know the French is trying to [ __ ]
everything [ __ ] their problems
I lose my British passport to say that's
just a joke that's fascinating that
Einstein figured that out too that he
literally had like a whole routine and
that he would drop this ball would hit
it bang and wake up and start writing
like saluting how he loves to be in the
room watching Einstein - that it must
been fascinating oh sorry I said I'd say
it's Edison my goodness I'm an idiot
Edison sorry changes everything that's
problem that was medicine a thief though
didn't he steal everything from Tesla